every once in a while something gets put
out by a financial institution that is
worth paying attention to and i just
read one of the most important pieces of
financial institution has put out in
probably the last decade now it came
from a gentleman named zoltan pulsar
most of you don't know who that is but
he's really really important he
currently is the global head of
short-term interest rate strategy based
in new york before he joined credit
suisse in 2015 he served during the
global financial crisis at the federal
reserve bank of new york he was in
charge of market intelligence for
securitized credit markets and he was
the point person on market developments
for the fed the treasury and white house
officials throughout the entire global
financial crisis then he was a visiting
scholar at the imf and then of course he
served as a senior advisor to the us
department of the treasury right before
he joined credit suisse zoltan is the
epitome of an insider of part of the
establishment he not only knows who the
players are he knows how they think he
knows the decisions that they make and
he is tapped into exactly what's going
on now this letter came out and what
it's titled is bretton woods 3 which
immediately caught my attention and so
we go ahead and we take a look here's
how zoltan started the piece he said we
are witnessing the birth of bretton
woods 3 a new world monetary order
centered around commodity-based
currencies in the east that will likely
weaken the euro dollar system and also
contribute to the inflationary forces in
the west he then continued and said a
crisis is unfolding a crisis of
commodities commodities are collateral
and collateral is money and this crisis
is about the rising allure of outside
money over inside money bretton woods 2
the system that we're leaving was built
on inside money and his foundations
crumbled a week ago when the g7 seized
russia's fx reserves now zoltan in the
middle of the article went ahead and
said the aggressor in the geopolitical
arena is being punished by sanctions and
sanctions driven commodity price moves
threaten financial stability in the west
we know that commodities are actually
exploding in price is there enough
collateral for margin is there enough
credit for margin what happens to
commodities futures exchanges if players
fail are ccp's bulletproof he then goes
on and says i haven't seen these topics
in the wide offering of financial
stability reports have you is the otc
commodity derivatives market the gorilla
in the room the commodities market is
much more financialized and leveraged
today than it was during the 1973 opec
supply crisis and today's russian supply
crisis is much bigger more broad-based
and much more correlated it's scarier
now zoltan finished his piece and he
said in this instance price instability
the surging and collapsing commodity
prices it feeds financial instability
margin calls may trigger the failure of
some smaller commodity traders and maybe
even some commodity exchanges he then
said again commodity correlations are at
one which is never a good thing the fed
and other central banks will be able to
provide liquidity backstabs but those
will be band-aid solutions the true
problem here is not liquidity per se
liquidity is just a manifestation of a
larger problem which is the russian
non-russian commodities basis and only
china will be able to close that he then
finished up saying do you see what i see
do you see inflation in the west written
all over this like i do the crisis is
not like anything we have seen since
president nixon took the us dollar off
gold in 1971 the end of the era of
commodity-based money when this crisis
and war is over the u.s dollar should be
much weaker and on the flip side the
renin be much stronger backed by a
basket of commodities from the bretton
woods era backed by gold bullion
pre-1971 to bretton woods 2 backed by
inside money to bretton woods 3 backed
by outside money gold bullion and other
commodities after this war is over money
will never be the same again and bitcoin
if it still exists then we'll probably
benefit from all of this zoltan is an
insider he understands this world better
than anyone putting out a note titled
bretton woods 3
from credit suisse
talking about the failures of the
western world talking about a weaker
euro dollar system explaining how the
east the pboc china and a
commodity-backed money is on the rise
the world order is shifting the monetary
order is shifting as well if you're not
paying attention i highly suggest you
tap in start understanding what's
occurring because quite literally your
financial well-being may depend on it
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time